hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to yawn dare a similar
now there's a few more things that I
want to try out first of which is Titan
mode don't my meeting all the copyright
musics it needs to be overridden holy
crap oh I'm sorry that's sent by over
there I got to get up to the roof
because I need to see this nope nope
nein there we go oh hi Jesus goddamn get
your boobs out of the school holy [__]
boobs McKenzie there's a dent in your
boob wanna talk to me
can you talk are you intelligible enough
high compliment today all the way up or
down there hey whoa don't look at me
don't look at me like that this is a
knife up here attack haha wait not who I
meant haha I'm a Titan Slayer
Peyton Slayer baby I'm Emma I'm one of
them what you call Titan Slayers I don't
know what they're called
ow ow ow ow ow ow well probably for the
best
only expelled well I don't know I don't
know why I did anything I just tried to
stop the Titans oh my my boobs gone hmm
okay now who's ready to do some Titan
slaying
oh what a normal day then all sudden
flash of light okay all right get ready
it's gonna go down
tonight ha gotcha that's one down oh yes
yes oh god that's so creepy oh god it's
so creepy okay here we go I don't know
what's gonna happen oh oh oh oh she's
just really tall oh here I was worried
that she was an insane creature and she
just turns out to be SuperDuper tall
okay all right
someone told me that this returns my
sanity a little more to normal so just
cut up all right let's go to school hey
hey fellow students I had a little bit
of chaos going on in my face still kind
of a little chaos going into my hair but
hey you know what let's attack this day
carpe diem every day's a new day even
you boobs McKenzie you know what you're
all riding my book because you know what
my little secret yeah I know I know I
know I know I know I know I don't know
what I know but you know what I know you
know you know oh yeah it's going there I
want to find every school everybody what
a great day for school why this is the
best that's so cool
ice and pie oh gosh oh gosh oh you're so
beautiful would you mind if I just pump
the back of your head with my crotch
yeah you don't mind right okay bye
that's good god jeez okay I'm just gonna
keep on walking I seem to be going
incredibly slow by the way
nothing wrong perfectly normal
this is normal this is what happens when
people go through puberty I think more
than muchos better oh not muchos better
out grass this is why I see over there
since I said why you can't run away from
a fight oh yes yes hi teacher oh hi how
are you doing oh just get back to normal
can't seem to there we go
oh this is my classroom oh I'm sorry
okay this I went in the same no no I'm
not what are you talking about I don't
know hello no a good school boy sure was
bad when those Titans attacked right
good thing we're all humans not Titans
in any way oh gods my what a good day of
school everybody so glad we went through
this day together so glad nothing bad
happen to anybody
well I'm just gonna carry on with the
wind in my hair and the beard on my
bouquet and apparently I'm supposed to
be able to actually do them things here
that are somehow related to actually
being a yandere and not just being
really really weird all the time not
that that's not what it is but it's not
what it is in my book hey hey oh it's
boobs McKenzie I forgot about that
hey hiya boobs McKenzie hey you don't
hear a thing I'm like a shadow in the
night wait I got to put on my sneaking
goggles wink she'll never see me coming
no one can detect me through all the
different layers our protection that I
am
my shadow light i am the darkness that
consumes those all your problems
okie-dokie so this is the way to take it
oh no oh that's sad I mean obviously
this whole game is about murdering your
opponent so I don't know how sad it
could possibly be
leave suicide note okay that's really
creepy
Oh cats don't go yeah they come you ow
look it up yeah there's another way to
go it involves like dumping water on a
student which would make them go oh gosh
oh gosh
Oh gasps Oh gasps Oh gasps Oh gasps Oh
gasps oh good golly gosh this is better
as a better batch a better one
yeah no it's good quality quality
quality right here that's quality stuff
yeah it's good stuff good stuff good
stuff yeah yeah yeah yeah that's that's
good stuff that's good stuff right there
all right so now I got this now no
definitely definitely we'll be able to
make this happen
yes I don't I do not have any blood on
me but I'll tell you who does have blood
on her somebody by the name of boobs
McKenzie why is boobs McKenzie the only
one that I get to pick on seems a little
unfair I mean I I I picked on her before
it even like revealed that she was just
joy for all bath huh
don't mind me Oh am i me I'm normal I'm
normal
perfectly normal I'll tell you who wait
what
but I don't have an option like drown or
anything what's gonna sorry I can't talk
right now yeah I want to ride you're
kind of dripping with what going on here
oh yeah
competition huh yeah who's who now yeah
yeah the work ah damn it
what about your poop what about your
poopy poop it's walking around with
cloud but it's a bunch of baloney all
right so that's all I know how to do off
the top of my head for yandere simulator
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you enjoyed this please let me know
down in the comments below and if I've
missed anything as part of the updates
let me know as well in the comments
below thanks again everybody and check
out the yandere simulator animation that
was made it's awesome and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]
don't notice me right now oh hi senpai
house